ever since the fed started to print
boatloads of money people have been
concerned about the potential of high
inflation for quite some time jerome
powell dismissed these concerns claiming
that if there was elevated inflation
readings it would be
in the transitory it will be transitory
and uh
um people need to have faith in the
central bank that we that we will do
that despite his confidence many were
still skeptical about inflation being
transitory i mean basic logic would tell
you that increasing the money supply by
6.4 trillion dollars would have some
sort of economic consequence
nonetheless jerome continued to claim
that inflation would be transitory
meeting after meeting after meeting
after a meeting with joe biden near the
end of last year however jerome would
basically turn on a dime suddenly jerome
thought that the word transitory should
be retired when it came to describing
inflation the word transitory has
different meanings to different people
to many it carries a time a sense of uh
of short-lived
we we tend to to
to
use it to mean that that it won't leave
a permanent mark uh in the form of
higher inflation i think it's it's
probably a good time to retire that that
word and try to explain more clearly
aside from admitting that inflation had
gotten way out of hand the entire fed
became extremely hawkish they went from
raising interest rates 0.25 per meeting
to 0.5 percent per meeting to 0.75 per
meeting now there's even rumors that the
fed will raise interest rates by a four
percentage point in one meeting despite
all their efforts we have yet to see
inflation peak in a meaningful way in
fact the latest cpi reading put
year-over-year inflation at a 9.1
percent and it seems like ten percent
could be just around the corner so what
happened to transfer inflation and how
did the fed get inflation so wrong
before we get into why the fed thought
inflation would be transitory i think
it's important to discuss what exactly
they meant by transfer inflation in the
first place many people often associate
transfer inflation with a transitory
price hikes but this is not what
transfer inflation means transduring
inflation simply means that the
inflation rating itself will come down
to normal levels of two to three percent
in such a scenario the price hikes would
still be permanent it's just the time
period in which prices were being hiked
wouldn't last that long for prices to
actually go back down inflation would
not only have to come down but it would
have to go negative and we would have to
see deflation this is obviously not
something that the fed promised
hopefully that cleared up the confusion
between transfer inflation and
transferred price hikes but why did the
fed even think that inflation would be
transitory in the first place
they literally just increased the money
supply by 33 within a matter of two
years well one of the reasons the fed
believed inflation would be transitory
is temporarily surging demand you see it
the first time we saw elevated inflation
readings was in the second quarter of
2021 this was shortly after vaccines
started to become widely available
throughout america so the theory was
that economic participation rose
significantly throughout this time
period as people start to freely go to
restaurants bars hotels vacations
shopping etc this unprecedented influx
of demand would of course allow
companies to raise prices but over time
it was expected that people would pull
back spending normal levels which should
theoretically ease demand and allow
prices to stabilize aside from this
temporary surge and demand the labor
market was still rather weak throughout
the first half of 201 we primarily saw
unemployment figures in the five to six
percent range as you can see this is a
rather high reading on a historical
basis so even though some people were
getting their vaccines and spending like
crazy a good portion of america was
still struggling to get a job and make
ends meet these guys were obviously not
going to be spending a bunch of money so
it was expected that these folks would
continue to weigh down demand which
should keep inflation in check the
problem with this theory however was
that the labor market would recover
faster than anyone expected usually it
takes several years for unemployment to
drop from percent to three percent but
this time it only took a matter of
months so not only were people spending
more money but the labor market was
stronger than ever on top of these
theoretical reasons i suspect recency
bias also played a role in the fed's
perspective ever since the 2008
financial crisis inflation has been
extraordinarily low in fact throughout
much of the 2010s the fed had to fight
to prop up inflation to 2 percent
because it kept dropping towards zero
not to mention it it's been nearly 50
years since we saw high inflation so it
wouldn't be that surprising here that
the fed's perspective was skewed by
recent economic history
alright so we've discussed some of the
reasons the fed believed high inflation
would be transitory but why did they end
up being so wrong well there were a lot
of factors that were out of their
control and they simply didn't pay
enough attention to these factors such
as the supply shortage the fed along
with business leaders have been
discussing the supply shortage since the
beginning but none of them really
expected things to get this bad the
overwhelming consensus was that supply
chains were simply having a bit of
trouble getting restarted a lot of
manufacturing plants had to rehire
employees implement new covert protocols
work around lockdowns and so on and so
forth so it wasn't that surprising that
we were seeing supply chain bottlenecks
as things eased back to normal though it
was expected that these issues would
just sort themselves out but we're
actually seeing the exact opposite take
place the supply shortage is worse than
ever and economists are predicting that
this could easily last for another year
even apple who has one of the most
established supply chains in the world
was predicting sales to dive by 8
billion due to shortages and lockdowns
so not only were we seeing rapidly
recovering demand but we were seeing an
unprecedented shortage in supply and
this turned out to be a deadly
combination supply wasn't the only area
in which we saw shortages either another
major shortage we've been facing it is
the labor shortage the mass layoffs that
came at the beginning of the pandemic
caused many to learn new skills look for
higher paying jobs and make themselves
more valuable this has made it extremely
difficult for companies to find low
level labor
take disney for example they have 33 000
less employees today than they had in
2019 a similar situation can be seen as
starbucks as well as these companies
struggle to find enough labor they're
being forced to pay higher salaries and
while this is great in the short term
for employees this eventually gets
passed on to customers leading to higher
inflation
so far we've covered the surface level
reasoning behind transfer inflation the
fed thought that inflation would be
transferred due to nb but they were
wrong because of cnd
this is the overwhelming narrative from
the mainstream media and even the fed
itself but what if they weren't wrong
what if they knew that inflation would
be high for quite some time now this may
sound like a conspiracy theory but hear
me out even if the fed knew that
inflation would be high do you really
think that they would just come out and
say it that would simply cause mass
panic and the fed wants to keep more
kids and people as calm and level-headed
as possible so it makes sense that they
would try to underplay how bad inflation
would get also i know a lot of you guys
think that the people at the fed are
idiots and that they have no idea what
they're doing but do you really think
that they would have missed something so
big i mean literally half of america was
calling for high inflation if a good
portion of everyday people could see
high inflation coming i suspect vet
members with a decade of experience
could also see it coming but then why
did the fed not take any action
well the thing to keep in mind is the
fed has two roles which are to maintain
low inflation and maintain low
unemployment throughout 2020 and march
of 2021 the need to boost employment was
simply a higher priority for them than
trying to minimize inflation in other
words they were okay with letting
inflation run hot for a year or two as
long as their policies boosted the labor
market it was until unemployment
cratered this up four percent in late
2021 that inflation became their number
one priority now that they're focusing
on inflation i don't think they'll go
easy on it i mean they didn't hesitate
to go from quarter percentage rate hikes
to three quarter percentage rate hikes
in a matter of months so i don't think
they'll hesitate to go to one percent or
even higher either as long as
unemployment is low and inflation is
high they'll pump up interest rates as
much as they need to
it's great that the fed is finally
taking serious action to combat
inflation but how long will it take for
inflation to actually cool down
well there is no secret formula to
calculate this but we can take a look at
history to guide our expectations over
the past hundred years we've seen five
notable peaks of inflation four out of
these five times inflation reached
levels of over 10 percent before peaking
but in 1950 inflation peaked at around
the levels that we're at right now from
the peak it took about one year and one
month for inflation to come back down to
two percent now of course past
performance is not indicative of future
results but if we were to assume that
something like this played out right now
we could expect inflation to cool down
by august of 2023 but that's just the
best case scenario inflation could
easily run to over 10 percent like it
did four other times in history in 1941
inflation continued to rise for another
seven months after reaching nine percent
after this it took 21 months for
inflation to actually come back down
similarly in 1974 inflation continued to
rise for another 11 months after
reaching nine percent and it took 23
months after this for inflation to cool
back down so we could easily see
inflation continue to rise into q2 of
2023 from there it could take to q1 and
285 for inflation to go back down to 3
percent so we're by no means close to
the end but we may be close to the peak
the fed seems to finally be taking
inflation seriously so chances are good
that we see a peak by the end of this
year but it's still a long way down most
of 2023 would still be elevated
inflation even though it would be
declining and it wouldn't be until 2024
or early 2025 that we see normal levels
even then we wouldn't be out of the
woods though both times we saw high
inflation in the past 100 years we saw
multiple peaks in the 1940s we saw three
peaks and in the 1970s we saw two peaks
so if inflation starts heading back up
in 2025 or 2026 we're likely in for a
full decade of high inflation
in the end the fed expected inflation to
be transferred due to a recovering labor
market along with expectations for
demand to cool down as a result they
were willing to let inflation run haunt
for a little as the economy recovered
but the labor market would end up
recovering faster than they expected not
to mention it we also saw the supply
shortage the labor shortage and the
ukraine russia war which screwed up the
fed's plan significantly at this point
inflation has already skyrocketed to
over 9
and all we can do is wait for the fed's
tightening to take effect and for
shortages to slowly ease unfortunately
neither of these are fast processes and
we're likely looking at a minimum of
another year or two of elevated
inflation ahead of us even if things do
cool down fast we can't let our guards
down because history has shown us that
inflation often comes in the form of
multiple peaks so we would have to
continue staying cautious to avoid a
second or even third peak but that's
just what i think when do you guys think
inflation will peak comment that down
below
also drop a like if you wish your salary
was inflating as fast as gas prices and
of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hurry and i'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]